since your time in Hollywood what 2006
when have you been your most broke huh
when I first got here I actually slept
in my car one night when I first got
here I stayed with my brother for a
while and his girlfriend at the time was
tired of me being there and so they were
like you got to get out and so I slept
in my car one night or two and then I
ended up staying with another friend for
a while in the beginning yeah I I've
always been decent with saving money
I've been lucky in that way so it didn't
take long for me to get a job waiting
tables and start saving up and stuff but
I've never been like $50,000 in credit
card debt I said for making the movie so
I mean that was probably our brokest
point was after we made the movie by
that's the truth of it because we had
$40,000 of credit card debt and at that
point I R had already saved up I saved
up 15 grand to put into the movie so I
already put my all my savings into the
movie and we had 40 grand of credit card
debt so that was probably my broke this
point after we made the movie but you
don't it was I never I never
second-guessed at once and I was proud
and happy to do it so so you slept in
your car do you remember what street
with town that was that's interesting
huh where was I think I was in El
Segundo that's why I lived down in South
Bay now and rebound a beach and I ended
up sleeping in my car that first I did
all my stuff at it was pretty crowded
but I was 23 at the time so you could
almost get away with it nowadays I think
I'd be like wake up you know once you
hit you early thirties you're not quite
the same anymore but yeah that was that
was my hardest time in LA and not
knowing anybody other than my brother
you know when I first moved here I had
no friends I didn't know anybody and and
eventually you start kind of getting a
family you know I was lucky I I did
acting school and so every you know
you're surrounded by people that are
going through the exact same thing that
you're going through starting out in LA
and and so you kind of become a family
you know and so you get new friends that
way
and you know all kinds of ways and it
becomes it comes your family here in Los
Angeles and I'm sure a lot of people
have the same feeling when they come to
LA they kind of start a new family in a
way because a lot of people come here
not knowing anybody one of the common
themes you've talked about is on things
not going as planned yeah my sense is
you like to plan like to be organized I
very much do I don't understand I was
helping a friend recently plan a movie
shoot and he has all these things hand
written on a paper I'm like all right
well let's type it out on the computer
and get every single location and the
address on on a on a page and every
single actor and you know every location
we're gonna shoot what time of day and
said why are we doing this and I'm like
what do you mean why are we doing this
like you have all the information in
your brain but you're gonna have a crew
of you know 15 people maybe more maybe
less but these people they have to know
what you're thinking and you can't
always be the one telling them it's very
easy to hand all this information so
everybody already has it all and when
they forget it they just look at the
piece of paper you know you have to save
that time so no everything's about
organization with the whole thing and
you have to organize to the last detail
because when you get there on the day
it's not gonna go how you planned and
there's always problems that arise with
wall-e
got wasted there was so many different
problems that arise I mean for one
certain locations we couldn't afford
permits you know certain places we had
permit certain places we didn't we got
shut down one day you know other days
I'd convinced security guards and police
officers to let us keep shooting you
know and all while he got wasted for
starters I convinced the crew from Teen
Wolf the TV show to come over on my
movie so I was like all the same people
who had worked together previously I'm
the new guy as the boss you know I mean
so that was really interesting dynamic
but they want nothing to do with cops or
security guards like if their union crew
so if they you know if they get any see
a cop or a security guy they're just
stopped working they don't want anything
to do with them there
no trouble no nothing so it's on me to
fix those problems so I might be acting
in the scene and a security guard comes
up and I'm like finishing the take real
quick and then turn and take care of my
my problem over here and then hopefully
convince them and then come back and do
my take or direct or whatever I'm doing
at the time so then the only place we
got shut down actually was my apartment
which is the funniest thing ever there
was one day we got shut down in my
apartment and basically the this scene
it's the iconic scene in the movie
actually the first time they bring the
body out in public and it's a
slow-motion scene and they're walking
with the body and actually if you look
at Patrick who plays Mitch in the movie
he looks left in the slow-motion scene
and he's looking at a woman who's
screaming at us going where's your
permit I'm gonna shut you down and
that's why he's looking left but it's in
slow motion you barely you know you have
no idea what he's looking at he just
glances left that's what he's looking at
some woman screaming at us telling us
you know where's your permit and so I
managed to get that take done and then I
went up to the woman was like hey I'm so
sorry did somebody bother you are we
bothering you or how can I help you she
was like I want to see your permit and I
was like okay well I just sent somebody
to go get the permit so why don't we
just I'm gonna shoot one more and then
and then you know and then I'm sure
somebody be back to show you the permit
she's like I need to see now I'm calling
the cops
and she has the phone right there and
I'm like okay I try my best you know so
I was like guys were shutting it down
everybody wanted to kill her you know
the crew they just set up all these
giant lights and everything the cast and
I was like don't talk to her don't
bother because I fully know that we have
to come back there three days later at
that date and shoot with cops and fake
guns and all he does I can't have the
cops be called now Brewer how the heck
am I gonna shoot here in three days so
I'm like no one would speak to her just
leave her alone and then one of my
actors said to it it was so funny while
James Batson who plays Wally he does a
phenomenal job he goes way to destroy
art how many passes there is his self ID
today because we were playing like
a silly comedy movie but and then
actually when we came back there three
days later she did end up calling the
cops and luckily she didn't do in the
daytime so there's a scene in the movie
where some dirty cops shoot somebody and
that was in the daytime and luckily were
between the two buildings and no one
called the cops because if a cop came up
and sauce with fake guns and police
uniforms they probably were to shut us
down but cops didn't get there till
nighttime and we saw the cop come and he
posts up about I don't know 50 yards
from my apartment on the street just
parks there and just watches and luckily
at that point we were shooting all the
SUV car scenes so we would we brought
this SUV between the two buildings and
we set up all the lights on the hood
pointing inward and the cameras on
attached to the hood of the car and how
are we gonna leave the cops right there
we can't drive around with this stuff on
there and nobody should do that I'm not
encouraging anyone to do this at all you
should get a tow truck and not drive a
car with lights pointing at your face
and a camera but we we had to do we had
to do at that moment and so basically I
got out of the car I turned off all the
lights I turn off the camera and luckily
there's no streetlight right outside of
my apartment so when we pulled out you
could only see the headlights of the car
and I turned laughter away from the cop
and we would drive down the street and
then I'd get out and turn out all on all
the lights and turn on the camera and
then we would just drive slowly on these
residential roads and shoot the scenes
so or parking in a parking lot and shoot
the scenes if you couldn't see out the
windows so that's what we did and then
we'd come back after 30 40 minutes of
shooting and drive faster and not past
the cop but close enough that he could
see us but there was no streetlights so
he couldn't I I'm assuming he couldn't
see the camera on the hood and the
lights and uh we managed to get away
with the whole thing
so my luck coming into play once again
so and then other days you know like we
shot at a casino and and we had no
business being at the casino we didn't
have permits but I'm showing up with a
you know three ton grip truck and and a
crew of 15 20 people they the nice part
is were so big that people assume we
must have permission to be there because
there's no way you would come and try to
shoot there without permission and we're
shooting at the parking lot of the
casino and the two security guards come
up and they're like it was like a scene
out of super bed they're like dude
where's your permit guys where's you you
guys have a permit you know and my
friend David Lee was helping with the
movie goes yeah we have a permit and
then they laugh and they go because if
you do it we don't give a haha and
they laughed and then they left they
didn't end up even looking at trying to
look at a permit so again luck came into
play there and another place a security
the head of security came and he came at
the absolute wrong time they were
because we were running next to
something it was slightly dangerous what
we were doing and it should have never
been done in the first place but I was
looking at the footage focused on the
camera and the first ad was trying to
get more footage and she was she was
like yeah Ron run Ronald quit Louise in
the movie one of my actors plays a dirty
cop run next to that moving object you
know and he did and it's not really safe
to do that and then the head of security
comes up right as he's doing that it's
like the worst possible time he could
come and and he was like whoa whoa what
are you guys doing here like this is not
safe you need a permit to be here and it
took like 20-30 minutes to talk to him
and convince them to let us stay there
and at the beginning he was totally
against it but I was like I saved up
this is my life savings like I saved up
all my money and this is I'm shooting a
big YouTube video because the moment you
say a feature they assume you have money
so I just told them to say YouTube video
and you can't shut me down and editor
died and you just please please please
and eventually after 20 minutes of
hearing me sob and talk you know and be
sweet and nice because I was never mean
you know he said fine you can shoot but
don't don't shoot there shoot you know
you could shoot on the stairs which
like doesn't make any sense to me you
could shoot on the stairs in the parking
lot well luckily and scheduling I knew
the hardest place would shoot would be
where most of the pedestrians were so we
shot that first and that's what he said
you couldn't shoot anymore well I
already had all the footage I needed up
there so and only one more take I needed
up there I figured we'd do it last now
that we got shut down and we shot the
stairs in the parking lot next and so I
scheduled just perfect knowing that we
had so much time and went show up with a
crew that I showed up with you usually
have some time if you start shooting
right away before people shut you down
because they're wondering what you're
doing there and they don't come up and
shut you down right away and I actually
had a defense for that because the crew
sees a security guard at a cop they
immediately don't do anything so I would
sometimes I would just go up to a cop or
security guard and be like hey how you
doing are you having a good night yeah
when do you get off oh that's awesome
cool well have a great night you know
and I would just walk away I would just
make small talk and walk away and the
crew would see me talk to the security
guard or the cop and be like oh okay
he's squared everything we're we're good
when really in fact I just talked to him
about their day and and was friendly but
see after I'm friendly too they assume I
must be there because people that don't
they're not supposed to be whether they
stay shy away they act like they're
being sneaky no I just come up
completely confront you'd be super nice
and walk away so they were like how do
you know about this they do a spy
there's so other security Isaac do you
know does a movie shooting here like
well let's call the boss you know like
and they'd call maybe their boss and
they don't know and then they call their
boss well meanwhile I already had an
hour and a half to shoot so I got some
footage and so that's a lot of part of
the scheduling is like you you have to
try to think of those kind of problems
and solve them so yeah that was and
sometimes cops would just be like oh we
saw you're shooting a movie but if I
have a lot of important equipment we're
just keeping an eye on you and they
would just watch us but I wasn't in
Hollywood I was in South Bay so where I
was in Pasadena or somewhere where you
know the cops if you do it in Hollywood
you probably are gonna get shut down and
some places you definitely do get shut
down I don't encourage people not to
have a permit you know but we had to
take the
because we just didn't have the money so
you know we'd go for it
you